do
so
[Music]
oh hello there what's up everyone
welcome back to hot breath
the show where you learn comedy from the
pros i am comedian
joel byers and every single week we are
doing q and a's with some of
comedy's comedies you know what i'm
already bombing
so let's just let's just get into it
ladies and gentlemen
our guest today we've done over 300
interviews but our guest today
is one of our most highly demanded this
guy knows comedy in and out and we're so
excited
to learn as much from him as possible so
without further ado
welcome to the hot breath verse the one
only mr chad daniels everyone welcome mr
daniels to the show here
yes that's when interviewing a comic we
i learned we got to get the
self-deprecation out of the way up front
we just gotta
get that out of the way before we jump
in
oh should they not have high
expectations for you chad
okay well jumping right into it
something
that i've learned in researching you is
you're um you like
comedy you enjoy comedians but there's
also that reality of comedy i've heard
you tell a story about
you know you hear of a comic saying i
paid my dues waiting an hour outside the
comedy store and then you're like oh
well
my dudes were sleeping in a walmart
parking lot you know if you could
there's a lot of young comics that
listen if you could kind of share
some just reality from a comic who
started
in 1998 some reality of what what does
it mean to pay
your dues in comedy
uh
[Music]
hmm
yep
like great but sometimes you're gonna
have to
not even get paid or get paid less than
the gas it took you to get there or
whatever it is i mean
you really do have to put in put in the
groundwork and
times are changing you know i'm i'm
stubborn
i don't do zoom shows i won't do
stand-up on zoom because
listen i'm a real and a baby when
i'm on stage and if i'm not getting the
laughs that i want
i'll tell the crowd i go hey you're not
doing your job i'm you know whatever
and i can't even imagine how bad i would
lose my mind on a zoom show
but we were talking before the mics were
hot and you were saying you do this
writing seminar
and you do you know all like the
uh fix a joke on facebook and all that
stuff
and and that's gonna be really important
because eventually
shows are gonna start happening again
and it's going to be
you and your group and the people that
are doing that across america that are
are building a foundation so they have
the
tons of stuff to go out with and then
you're going to have old stubborn guys
like me
that are going to get left in the dust
because we're like yeah i didn't do
i walked my dog i raked my leaves i have
no more funny stories for
since march 8th so i think what you guys
are doing is very
important too as you know with the new
climate of comedy
wow yeah thanks for saying that and it
is tough and it all started honestly
with
me being in comedy 10 years and all of a
sudden all my road work is gone and i'm
like
sure what am i gonna do and it was kind
of like i need some sort of
accountability
you know is what i started to like ask
okay how can i be accountable i guess
i'll start writing online every day and
i would just film myself
writing for 10 minutes you know and
saying like here's what i came up with
and it just kind of organically grew
into this online community
that um has been it's been a game
changer for me and
for a lot of the people in it and i i do
feel
inspired that there are comics who do
like the feedback mic
in our facebook group and things that
then say i did it at a zoom show and it
worked really well or i did it at a live
show and it worked really well
but it's you got to be willing to do the
work at the end of the day
like you can get all the techniques you
can get all the tips
but you've got to get on stage and put
them to work
yeah that's true there are so many
talented people
in this industry but the amount of
talent it takes to just
go up and wing it 100
is off the charts and you you rarely see
somebody that can do something like that
yes yes but that's i feel like that's a
a a young comic like um
what is it mirage where you see like
dave chappelle talking and they're like
oh he's just talking
i could do that and then the you may
strike you may
strike lightning once but that's not
sustainable if you just go up in riff
and be like oh i'm the magical comic i
i hacked it it's like no right and and
once
you know you have to have such a
plethora of
knowledge to do that i mean you need
such a vast
pond from which to grab these facts
and situations and because
if you're riffing hey man there's a good
chance you're going to be
wrong eventually and that's no fun
either because
once once that little crack shows up
that little crack in the dam the crowds
start picking at it and picking at it
and it is not fun it's like blood in the
water
so it's it's that moment when the laughs
get quieter and quieter and then the
the harder you fight like the tighter
you get into the quicksand
yeah absolutely
what is that like i i read where you on
your
like your comedy central taping in like
2008 i think
the audience wasn't laughing loud enough
and you like called him out on it
is that something you did well it is i
mean so here's the situation let me
i don't
so you know you you work hard and you're
out on the road and you finally get this
this break and you want it to go well
and there was a
a show that ended up on xm i believe at
the time
it was a new york terrestrial radio show
uh and it was opium anthony it was
called oh yeah and
robert kelly who is just so
fantastically funny yeah and
just such a good dude as well but um
he he was set to go up with another
comedian
that i'm not going to name but then that
comedian didn't want to share the crowd
with robert kelly
because robert kelly's show sold out
first out of
all of the taping so how it works is two
comedians share the same crowd
so they basically get you know just over
an hour of material because you're
doing 40 so they can do edits and stuff
and then he was huge on opie and anthony
and opie all these opie and anthony guys
i'm gonna tell you they are people that
uh
you know a lot of them in the front row
had uh
chains outside of turtlenecks it just it
felt very what i
i'm from minnesota right so it felt
very bon jovi to me
and uh and they weren't laughing and
they were sitting with their arms folded
and stuff and so i just
i absolutely unleashed on them and then
it was great after that it was so much
fun
i told them you know i'm going to go i'm
going to do a full hour 20. you're not
going to see robert kelly
i just kind of basically said i know you
don't know who i
am but god damn it laugh anyways and
uh and they were very nice and and came
around and decided like oh all right
this
little punk actually wants this to go
well so
uh yes but but it was fun and i told
robert kelly that story
um in montreal a couple years ago and
man
he he was just laughing at the fact that
he almost
uh you know took the train off the
tracks there
yeah he uh yeah we had him on here and
it was a good interview after he stopped
roasting me
him and rich voss just had to like break
me in before we could even get to the
interviews absolutely yep that makes
sense
[Laughter]
what is like what is the worst i always
ask comics on here like a story of
getting booed
or just like their most unforgettable
bomb what is that for you
um i've had i've had several i was in uh
doing a bar show there was a confederate
flag up
in front of me and the comedian that
came with me
friend of mine african-american guy and
he went up and he's like
doing the old hey this is funny and this
is funny
and i went up and i was just like as i
was watching my friend do this
i was getting more upset and more upset
and so i went on stage
and took the flag down and uh
you know told them blah blah blah and
then this guy
probably not loaded i will say but did
wave a gun and i'm like
jesus christ you gotta be kidding me
right now
over a backdrop i mean come on
at least they didn't throw anything at
you yeah it's very true
but there were uh it was booing loud
booing and then i'm sure
other words with hard case at the end um
yes yes yes yes yeah those are
nobody that's another thing i like young
comics to hear is just
people the stories of people bombing so
they know that they're not the only ones
like i feel like comics feel like you
graduate from bombing at some point
but i feel like no one's really immune
to it
sure i heard a great story that bill
burr was telling that
um you know he was starting to get
uh starting to sell tickets from people
that knew what they were getting into
and so he was just
on this you know automatic crush mode
and then he went in to do a guest set in
chicago
but the comedian that was headlining
that week they were completely
opposite of what bill burr is and so a
lot of the people in the room
didn't know who bill burr was and so
billboard struggled for a while to get
them back and
and that is saying something too it's
like when you do get a crowd
it is nice to go out and try to make
people laugh
that aren't part of your crowd to see if
your jokes it's like do these work
all over the place or uh you know are
they just working because people are
here to
to see me yeah that's something i had to
discipline myself i started commenting
in atlanta so i could do like
go to the hood of atlanta and do a spot
go to the hipster bar and do a spot and
then like go to like uh like the punch
line
and do a spot and it was kind of like if
a joke worked in one place and not the
other
then i would get rid of it because it
would it would be like super specific to
that audience and not
translate when i when i'm in like you
know charlotte north carolina or
something like that sure
absolutely yeah that's a good move and
and same with like local references and
everything like that
because there are times where i'll be
watching and someone would be like and i
can't believe these from
panda luca and everyone goes nuts and i
just go oh i don't
i don't know panda luca
[Laughter]
what do you do when you have a joke
that's working
and then all of a sudden it stops
working
well i record every single set that i do
on my phone
and so i just go back a month before
and see and i pull that little
chunk out of the set and then i listen
to them one after another to see what's
different
and because that's all it'll take it'll
take
you know you add something that you
think is funny but it's a sentence that
doesn't need to be there and it takes
whatever it's dividing there's too big
of a lull
in it to it's not a bridge it's more of
a gap
and so you'll end up losing momentum and
it'll take it from
you know a hard laugh to a chuckle or
sometimes even an applause break to a
confused look i mean it can be that
significant geez
oh wow that's that's oh yeah i mean i i
say record
every single every single set that way
you just have reference to go back
but it's recording as one level and then
actually listening to it is
it's like another level of
responsibility comics have to remember
to do
yeah you just i mean i get a coffee and
it's the first thing i do in the morning
because i can't stand my own voice
you wouldn't know that considering i've
let you say four words so far
you're doing great but uh you're the
guest you're supposed to be the one
talking
but but yeah you just you have to listen
to it
otherwise you know it's it's you know
how you can watch another comedian
and then you're like oh i got a tag for
you i mean when you listen to yourself
if you really listen and dial it in
you'll come up with tags and and figure
out why stuff doesn't work and why it is
working and whatever else
yeah i'll consider listening as part of
writing like because you do find new
tags and ideas
just from listening to a set yeah that's
true
do you do pen to paper like how do you
and actually
this would be i um your your ihop story
maybe maybe we could use this as almost
like a template for your writing
your uh writing technique but you have
this story
of you going to ihop with your family
and then something happens
so as a comedian we're always looking in
life of like oh how can i take that to
stage but how do you take an experience
like
going to waffle house with your family
and making it a joke that's like
laugh laugh laugh laugh i was actually
in a car with uh just just hilarious
comedian out of st louis sean o'brien
and he makes me laugh so hard and i was
telling him this story
and you know he's kind of uh he's an
east coast guy
and so he's got that kind of tough edge
to him and doesn't laugh
at everything you say if it's stupid
he'll just look at you and i was telling
him this story because it just happened
and he was laughing so hard and he goes
you you tell that on stage and i'm like
well no i'm not doing a bit on you
and he goes you have to so st louis was
the first place i tried it because
i told my buddy sean about it and he's
like you gotta do that on stage and so
i brought the the bones of it on stage
and then you try to figure out
you know what else can i do here how can
i
you know the end of it is a call back to
a joke about my son and so
he figured out but i think for me
getting putting a story on stage is do
you think it's funny
you know if something happens to me that
morning i always do it on stage just to
see
but when i when someone who doesn't
laugh at everything and you find
incredibly funny laughs
then i think that's a good tester to to
bring it up there and when you say you
bring the bones on stage do you
like you tell the story to sean and then
do you then go and kind of create an
outline of like different beats within
the story that are the bones of it
well i just knew that the main punch
line of the story was going to work
because it you know it was
that's what made me laugh that's what
made sean laugh the hardest and so i
knew as long as i could get
there and then you try to get little
laughs on the way there
you know and try to build them up after
show after show and that's why i record
but
um one yeah if you have a big laugh that
you know
even if it takes you a minute to get to
an applause break
then you know you can go back and find
laughs before that to build up to it
so you know that's what i talk about the
bones is that
one big laugh and an actual a story
around it even if it's not that funny
because then you'll be able to get be
able to shake the funny out of it
eventually
and do you find the laughs along the way
and i'm assuming the big line is
is your daughter what your daughter says
is that like the big laughs
yeah okay so is it in finding leading up
to
that line is it like to add laughs is it
details is it do you have like a
checklist of almost okay i need to add
some funny to this story
let me look for contrasting ideas or let
me look for
misdirects do you kind of go through a
mental checklist
i try not to do too many misdirects um
i just try to to paint a picture with la
just to try to really build up to what i
know is going to work
and so whether that's details whether
it's letting the people in on
you know a very personal aspect of your
life for example i bring my kids to ihop
i show them pictures of the city that i
was just in
um and then you then you you
you know you can make fun of ihop it's
the fact that the tables there
are so incredibly sticky and of course
they are it's an it's a pancake place
and syrup goes on pancake of course it's
sticky
but everybody knows that and everybody
is like yeah
gross it is stick you know so you kind
of build and you kind of gain their
trust with that first part of the story
and then you can go in and
you know get the laughs and then the big
laugh towards the end and
oh i mean i'm saying all this with the
parenthetical
hopefully that's how it works but not
always
over time i mean i've heard bert
christopher say his machine story took
him like four years or something like
that to develop
so it's a process absolutely
and we got some questions popping in
here
as well there's one more uh napping
while
dreaming sean in the building matthew
zombie robot sheep sasha oh a few john's
in here
oh good to see everyone dan and shauna
maynard say hello
oh right back at him very nice evelyn in
here as well
bo looks like a bo has a question here
and um i do want to ask this
before we jump into the questions and
people watching
do um do go ahead and post some
questions in the comments and we'll get
chad to
answer them for you well before we get
started let you let
you said dan maynard said hello and of
course shauna but i want to say to dan
maynard i want to say you owe me an
explanation
on your facebook post brother
that's it that's that i'm using this
as a as a way to get to him to tell him
give me the deets all right i'm ready
yeah dan
your face maynard oh and jeremy alder
says hey chad as well and michael
wolfelmeyer very nice
well look at this look at all the people
showed up we out here
so hear me my son not a lot of people
know that
oh he says dan says you got it so okay
perfect
this is um the the last thing i want to
touch on before we get to
uh viewer questions as well is uh about
the business side of comedy and
something you've had a lot of success
with
is streaming on the audio side i mean
the number i heard was you've had over
like 750 million streams
sure on over across your five albums so
like i'm not sure what the number is
it's not like that
it's like it's it's up there though and
that's i just
i just released um i self-produced my
own comedy special
and released it on my 10 year
anniversary and i released the audio
onto sirius
so i've gotten a taste of residuals of
like
what's possible with it you know sure so
how
um you can you can even direct this
advice at me if you would like but more
of like how can comics
build momentum on these streaming
platforms because they can be
sustainable income really
okay so how do we get people
that are already on pandora are already
on spotify
right you can't really direct people to
xm because that's that's an extra
right people have that and that's they
don't search you out on xm and sirius
they just
they play you and that's it pandora and
sirius however they have to search you
out they have to make a station
they have to do those things so what i
did
and i don't know if this would work for
anyone else but i just got little beer
coasters
with the picture of my album it was
called
uh which one did i do footprints on the
moon
and then on the back of it it said um
check out chad on pandora make a station
and then it gave the i don't even know
what it's called url
and so i would hand those out after
shows i would just sit there and hang
out
and you know they they don't cost much
in the grand scheme of things and so
i was like oh you guys going to the bar
next door all right hey here's some
coasters and sometimes you can get the
uh the club to put the coasters on
the table and then people will just
pocket them and then they get home and
then
they're hung over the next day so
they're looking at this and like i got
nothing else to do
chained to the toilet right now may as
well blah blah and they
make a station then
uh all the people that have your station
there's something on pandora called amp
amp where you can make your own
commercials
right so right now i can make
i'll pull this up while i'm doing this
but i can make uh
a commercial for um
all right so right now
okay so 428 000 active listeners
and i can make a commercial that will go
to
all of them right when they start the
station
and it'll say like hey this is chad
daniels thanks for listening to my
station
uh hey check out you know
this on this check out my new podcast
middle somewhere check out blah blah
and then that's a commercial that goes
out to everyone that has a station for
you
so what you what you really are trying
to do with this
is get people to make a station of your
standup in order to have a station
you have to have content on pandora of
course and then
you know people listen and i will tell
you that pandora and spotify
money is not the same as except xm money
uh it's like you know a very very small
fraction of a penny per listen
but uh but that that's the way to get
there and then you get people listening
to it
you know you're in a pandemic you're not
on the road you have a podcast
people can still listen to your material
it's accessible it's free for them
um so that's that's what i did as far as
like getting more
lis i don't know i don't know how it
happened
um certainly very thankful
that nobody gave me you know i sent a
message to pandora
just openly and i said whoever put my
stuff on all the stations
i'd like their name so i can send them
something
and they wouldn't tell me they were just
like keep sending us your album sounds
like all right
so it was you know i've had um
[Music]
i've worked hard but i've had man if i
had some luck and some
some good people around me and in my
corner so
um be nice
that has been such a common phrase we've
been saying is be
nice and be funny like period yeah sure
that's so it's what what are what are
some other kind of strokes of luck
that like that you've had throughout
your career
i had so um
[Music]
i worked with a guy in all right let me
start over
in minneapolis there used to be two
comedy clubs one was acme where i
started the other one was at the mall of
america and that was called
knuckleheads and so right
the the guy that booked knuckleheads his
name was rich miller
and he also booked tulsa
san antonio and austin texas
and so once you emceed at knuckleheads
and were a minneapolis guy
and you were ready to feature he would
send you to tulsa
as like the test to get to go to san
antonio and austin because those were
his babies
same with austin austin has a great
comedy scene
and it was the same with them when
somebody was ready to feature they'd
send them to tulsa to see if they could
go to minneapolis so it was kind of a
foreign exchange student a little bit of
a flip-flop yeah yeah
so i went down to tulsa i worked with a
guy named john morgan
he's out of baton rouge louisiana and he
crushes maybe harder than anyone i've
ever seen crush
and we were in a condo together which is
basically to say
the the club buys a house so they don't
have to pay for hotel rooms
and then you kind of just share the
house you have your own room you have
your own everything but
um you share the house and john and i
really hit it off
and john called who did he call he
called dave stroup
out of columbus ohio who books i think
all the funny bones which is just like
a massive amount of work he called
freddy demarco
from deja vu comedy club not i know
everyone
thinks deja vu is a strip club but
there's deja vu comedy club
in uh in missouri and
uh those two gave me
so much work and freddie demarco got me
into auditioning for the montreal comedy
festival
and this is all because i happened to
work with this guy
and get along with him so well and he
was so nice and
he just he basically said book this so
he normally had to send a tape to get
booked and he just called them both and
said
nope book him right now while while i'm
here i want him to fill out his calendar
and my calendar was basically booked
after that and so
you know that's one when i was very very
new
i was a bartender and i worked at a
place called the eagles nest
and uh this lady named ron and cindy
owned it and this lady named cindy
so wonderful she would give me the week
off to go work comedy
and then when i was back she would
give me the shifts of the people that
had covered for me on the other week so
i was constantly working
and without that income you know i had a
new baby
so without that income there's just no
no way i would have been able to make
that happen
and and uh probably the biggest and i
know
people this might weird people out but
my ex-wife
was the most uh
understanding and she you know she had
all the faith in me in the world
and so if you don't have something like
that i mean she basically worked
full-time she's a college professor
and then she also watched two children
and i know they're hers but
raised two children while i was on the
road
and she had faith in me so she allowed
me to do that you know i get
a lot of young comedians are like my
girlfriend's pregnant how did you make
it work it's like
i don't know this feels like a lightning
strike what happened to me because
my ex is you know there's
no way i'm at where i'm at right now
without her support no chance
wow and you say why she's your ex
well that's for the next podcast i
wasn't gonna go there we're keeping
comedy related
we don't want any blue jokes in here
nope yeah so i mean it's it really is
it's it's all of that stuff you know and
so
yeah it's uh like i said you work hard
but
you need some breaks being nice and
being funny you were nice to the guy
and you were funny and he was willing to
like refer you
so being nice and being funny sure
nice well i'll i don't want to i want to
be nice and
answer some other comics questions as
well
all right but we are yeah we're deep in
here
oh this is a this is an interesting
observation ak40
says chad is an underrated comic i think
he's saying by choice i think chad is an
underrated comic by choice i think if he
would have moved to l.a or new york 10
years ago
he would be a household name
that's very nice do you agree
we'll never know we'll never know there
are times in this you know it's gonna
make me sound like mr dad but there are
times people do ask me that in
interviews they'll ask
do you ever think about what you missed
out on by not moving to la or new york
and
and as lame as this sounds i mean the
real answer is
i know what i didn't miss out on
by staying in minnesota so i mean you
know my kids are
i think for the most part happy and well
adjusted
and i was able to come back and just
kind of have a home base there's not
comedy here
right so when i was home that was it i
was just home and
um so i guess i don't know
i mean who knows i might have stuck a
needle in my arm and died in a gutter if
i lived in la
nobody knows but uh that's very nice of
ak-40 to say that
all right let's let's scroll
needle in the arm got a little dark in
the arm it just made me think i was just
taking it to a different a
whole different level all i could think
well i knew you had worked with mitch
hedberg but i didn't know how closely
so i didn't know where how closely the
needle
reference landed no mitchell's uh
man so talented and so fantastic
how how much did you work with him i
worked with him a lot so
i started in minneapolis and i did open
mics for a while and then i
got offered an audition to move to
grand forks north dakota which is just
on the border of minnesota and north
dakota up
closer to canada and i didn't know
anything about it and i went up
there for an audition week and i had uh
minneapolis legend darlene westgore
was the feature and mitch hedberg
was the was the headliner on my audition
week and this was
right after he signed his huge
development deal
in montreal with fox he got a 500 000
development deal pretty much unheard of
at this point but time had just come out
with an article
saying he was uh the happy stephen
wright
you know just like he was getting so
much momentum and so much press
and so when i got there all these
comedians from minneapolis had
had driven up and so i just left him
alone and then he sought me out because
i was leaving him alone
to the point where we hung out all
weekend he had me in his room after
shows
because he just he was like i like you i
want you around
which was fascinating to me because i
can be really annoying but
i mean when i went back there after i
got the gig
i was at a bar and i didn't have my id
and uh one of the other the bouncer was
like you can't come in
no way and i was with the people that
worked at the club and there the bouncer
was like i don't care
and then another bouncer came up and
goes hey let him in that's mitch
hedberg's friend
and i was like holy so i didn't
know i don't know if mitch hedberg would
have said that
at that time um but it was pretty cool
using someone else's coolness
i've never done that before and it felt
awesome i totally get why people do it
did you guys keep in touch like did you
work together a lot more
yeah so in the six months i was there he
came back two more times
so he was yeah he was just like everyone
loved him so much i mean he packed the
room and
he was great friends with the owner
chris who's another fantastic guy
um and then chris
booked him the guy that owned the club
booked mitch on some other gigs and le
and had me open for him and
so uh actually the first weekend i ever
worked with mitch on my audition week he
brought me down to open forum
on a one night or on the sunday night
which was i thought was
fascinating because i just felt the
coolest i've ever felt
yeah to do a one-nighter i love that
i mean you know he's actually you know
those blue sunglasses that he was always
wearing kind of famous for
yeah he bought those on the way from
minneapolis to grand forks that weekend
so i just feel like a little you know
i'm just such a comedy nerd
oh you are too no i mean well absolutely
i mean i loved comedy since the time i
was little
but just to just to kind of be like oh
i you know i was there the weekend he
bought those glasses
it's so nerdy but it's also so fantastic
oh of course no i i love that i mean
mitch was the guy
like oh he's the comic i sounded like
when i started like
when comic starts out they just absorb
whoever they hear
mitch was the guy i sounded like i just
loved the structure and the absurdity
and just the contrast i mean he was he
was my favorite and still one of my
favorites
yeah anytime mitch would go to a city
everybody
had that little pot smoker laugh by the
end of it every open micro
and i had the guy booked knuckleheads
rich i told you about he came up to me
after a set and he goes you start
smoking weed that i don't know about it
and i was like no and he goes well then
stop laughing like it you sound like an
idiot
i was like all right thank you that's
why it's important to listen to your own
sets also
because i found if i listen to myself i
sound like myself more but if i listen
to a comic too much i start sounding
like that comic
makes sense yeah so let's see
uh a few more i just i just mitch
yeah mitch hedberg he's just yeah um
oh here's a bo johnson
um what do you do in those moments that
you feel the material well is dry
and you'll never write anything funny
again
stop pushing it that's what i do i mean
when i try to think of a name
the i can know the name before i start
the story i can actually
think the name and then i start the
story i'm like oh what's that name again
and then the more i think about it the
deeper it goes
the deeper it buries itself so when i'm
not writing
i just i don't write and then
eventually it slowly comes back and then
you'll find you know you won't write
anything for
three months and then you'll write 45
minutes of material in three weeks
so um i just wouldn't put that much
pressure on it because it will come back
um see you're more at least at least for
me i can't tell bo johnson
that it will come back for them but
for me it does yeah that's it's always
interesting to ask comics that because
like we talked to ted alexandro
and he's like right every day regardless
type deal and
showing up and doing the work you know
treating it like a job
you go to other jobs when you don't feel
like it so he's like so right when you
don't feel like it but for you
it's more of like if you don't you don't
force it and then when
when it does reveal itself you really
tap into it
well i will write what's happening i'll
journal i will write what's happening in
my life
but if i'm not feeling funny and i get
frustrated
i just journal as i would actually
journal right i just okay
that way i don't forget the stories i
don't forget what's happening i don't
forget my
you know emotional presence in a story
so i still have that to look back on and
i'll
tommy jonathan does that too go back
he'll put the journal away for a month
go back and look at it yeah
and this ties in uh jason fox asking uh
do you have a regular writing schedule
do you already have something in mind or
you just start writing whatever comes to
mind
normally i have to have something i have
to have a little tidbit of an idea
and i don't necessarily have a schedule
i mean there are times where i'll have
to turn off
a tv show or i'll have to leave a movie
theater so i can
write some stuff down in my notes well
this was back when i went to movies but
um bedtime is a big one for me
you know i go to bed at old man time and
there are times where i'm still up at
midnight leaning over my
little end table by my bed writing stuff
so
it just depicts you know um it strikes
when it strikes and you think about it
when
when you think about it so i would just
say actually
speaking of hedberg has that great joke
um sometimes i'll think of a bed i i'm
gonna butcher it but sometimes i'll
think of a joke
in bed and a pen won't be close to me so
i have to spend the next five minutes
telling myself it wasn't funny
so i would say always have a pen on you
or your you know your phone with your
notes app or whatever it is but
yes yes honor the ideas by writing them
down
sure yeah and you seem disciplined i
could have said that whole thing
go ahead i could have said why just
you're way better at paraphrasing i'm
talking for five minutes and then you're
like honor the ideas i'm like oh yeah
three words i could have said right
there that sounds good no you had a lot
of gold in there i just wanted to
boil it down for the comics here you
know word economy
you know comedy is brevity
um this is uh
this is interesting this is from
alejandro
uh what can we do when the people
misinterpret a joke and a heckler
screams
racist ooh it's interesting
um well that at that point
it it depends you can say you know you
can react however you want how i would
do it
is i don't say anything on stage that i
don't believe in
and that i haven't thought about i mean
there are times something will come off
the cuff
and if and if i say it and i'm like oh
that didn't feel right i will
immediately
say hold on that didn't feel right and
then i'll break it down with the
audience in the room
just because it's like if you had to
hear me say those words
then you're also going to hear me figure
out why i thought they were wrong
what i think would be right we're going
to sit through this together
but i would say if you really believe in
something
and you have the facts to back it up
then
ask i would just ask why they think it's
racist
you know i would i would start a
dialogue
i mean i can't do colleges anymore
unless i just do a town hall meeting
so i'll start off with one bit and then
we'll go around the room
i i do 15 minutes of material and
you know my college shows last an hour
and it's because we're just talking
about
the material because i think when you
let people
voice their opinion they're gonna have
it right but then you have an
opportunity
to not only figure it out with that one
person
but all the other ears are hearing it
the dialogue too
so i think it's just an opportunity when
someone calls you a racist to say
why do you think that wow that's gold
i don't know if that's true it might get
somebody shot but that's my answer
he's gonna alejandra is gonna get i had
a similar experience like i have a joke
in my special
comparing uh chinese people to mexicans
because i was a dishwasher
it all started out as a dishwasher i was
working with mexicans and i was like we
use
mexicans for x y and z and i was like oh
we also do that with chinese people so
then i was starting to brainstorm what
other parallels there are
but in working that joke out i did get
heckled
as i was racist several times working it
out
because i'm just so white i look like
the white devil
like but i'm just his son i swear but i
really me just saying another race makes
people uncomfortable
so i had to over time find what the
funny angle on it was and not me just
saying mexican and chinese people
yeah i mean that makes sense there's uh
there's certain words
for guys that have faces like you and i
that no one wants to hear come out of
them
and for great reason historically great
reasons yeah
yes or sad reasons but understandable
reasons for sure
um let me
there was one more in here i want to
slide and then we have a special guest
i want to bring on here um
where'd it go here it is uh jeremy alder
uh my son yes yes your son
yeah you guys do look a lot alike we so
we were at a brewery in north carolina i
think it was at the brewery yes it was
for sure
and uh doing a show for uh my college
agent
and these girls came up to me and go you
look like his son
and he's like two years younger than me
that piece of
you look so good oh this makes me
furious
oh i thought you i thought you were
kidding but you actually know jeremy
i do oh that's great yeah he's he's been
uh hanging out in our daily writing club
as well that's awesome oh yeah that
makes sense he's uh
fantastically funny very nice all right
jeremy representing the hot breathaverse
here
so he asks uh have there been moments
in your development when you could tell
you had leveled up in your ability in
some way
that you had reached a new level in your
skill
uh i i think all those moments came in
hindsight
you know i don't think i've ever felt
well i guess that's not true because i
have let me i'm gonna explain it this
way there have been times
where i have seen people get things i.e
comedy central specials and i go
well i could do that i should do that
right and you have that thought before
you do it
and then you do it and then afterwards
you're like
i don't think i was ready for that a
couple years later you were like i would
have much rather
done it now than then why was i beating
the door down
to show off my mediocrity i mean it
doesn't make any sense so
um i think that yeah i mean
some things come in hindsight all
comedians know that when you record an
album or have a special
you'll watch it or listen and go that
joke wasn't finished that one wasn't
done
and you know the crowd doesn't know that
because they're having fun and
and they don't know that you could have
added another level or
or whatever but um so i don't think in
the moment i ever feel that way
but there are times where i can look
back
and just you know not be such a harsh
critic and i can go
oh i guess that is the around the time
when this happened or uh when i feel
like
um you know i i used to
make fun of individuals in the crowd for
not laughing
and now i i refuse to do that i will
give them percentages
because that way people have a choice
they can
everyone wants to be part of the
majority right so if you say ah 14
of you aren't laughing right now and uh
but great news 86 that's a that's a huge
number
and then people you know some people
won't like you and they'll be like yep
14 right here but some people will be on
the fence and not even know they weren't
laughing because they're
not outward laughers and they'll go well
i'm going to be part of the 86 does he
think i'm part of the 14
so instead of calling out individuals i
started doing that and that's one of
those moments where i thought oh this is
a way smarter way to go about it
fun oh that's a fun another fun tip
there yeah
you said don't you dare steal it don't
you dare take my percentage
oh they're gonna be in the back of the
room oh he's doing the chad daniels
percentage thing
yeah yeah classic classic hack right
there
classic daniels he loves a good
percentage
so let's uh let's get into in these
final few minutes here
we have um a special guest i want to
bring on
because a lot of these podcasts um
the guests the uh the fans actually book
guests
on the podcast and you i've been a fan
of yours for years
but one of our listeners actually took
action and reached out to you
on social media and made this whole
thing happen so wonderful
i thought he's a he's a newer comic
actually based here in the atlanta area
but
he's already producing his own shows
he's already doing like a lot
of uh he's taking a lot of action in his
career which is what we're all about
here at hot breath
nobody likes a go-getter but anyways
create your own
success is what we like here
so um i just want to bring him on for a
few minutes to like just
ask some questions to you because i know
he's a big fan as well
so ladies and gentlemen of the hot
breath verse welcome the one and only
john chapple everyone let's welcome john
chapple
hey johnny
can you can you you're sideways there we
go
and are you at a show right now i'm
outside an open mic
yeah i love it well this is uh
john and chad john he's here you did it
man
thank you for coming i appreciate it
absolutely thanks for getting me on
yeah we've already learned so much in
the first part so have you gone up at
the open mic yet are you waiting to go
up
no i'm waiting it starts in about 15
minutes oh i got you okay nice
yeah did you have questions for chad or
anything john i do
i have a few questions sure so uh one of
the questions
i had is being that you're
in comedy for over 20 years now was
there any point where you thought about
quitting almost daily
and and i know that seems like a funny
answer but there are
you know it's when you have
children and you travel and um
you have a wife at home and you're at
airports
and you almost have to turn on
a psychopath gene which we all have
to leave your loved ones to go eat
in front of strangers
i mean there's something that you you
almost have to break it
in a specific way for it to make sense
and uh you know there are times where
you're just like
what am i doing out here but then
that's a little part of the day the
majority of the day you're like
i don't know what else i would do this
is what i want to do it's what i've
always wanted to do since i was little
uh someday if i'm present
with my kids if i never miss anything
important
they i hope will understand
and you know my 21 year old and 16 year
old we've had so many conversations
about this and and they seem to
understand
that um
that i just probably wouldn't have been
as happy
dry walling or something
yep gotcha and how about you
well i've only been in for eight months
i did uh three open mics before
covid hit so i just wrote wrote for
most of it sure absolutely so eight
months
30 days it's 240 you've thought about
quitting 240 times
it makes sense to me
i don't think i'm at the point where
i've thought about quitting yet sure i'm
still in the uh
what do they call that the uh the
honeymoon honeymoon phase yeah
absolutely yes so it's it's just nice to
get on stage and
get more comfortable i agree you know my
last show
uh before summer was in spokane that was
march 11th
and i didn't go back on the road until
the end of july and i had some shows in
st louis and indy and uh
fort wayne indiana and columbus ohio and
i just man oh man getting back on stage
and having people allow you to kick the
rust off
without freaking out and being like this
is horrible spit it out fat tongue
you know it was really nice to have
the support of the people you know we
just went through an election and that's
countries torn but i will tell you this
it's like
you got people coming in who voted for
one guy people coming in who voted for
another guy
and they just wanted to be part of a
good show and a fun show and
and you know not to sound too douchey
and like la ti doll let's get together
but you see it happening all the time so
you know i i i think that
i know you didn't ask me about politics
but i think the media loves to drive the
divide home
but when you go out in public especially
at a comedy club
and you're there it's like people really
do seem to be
to be getting along and just want to
have fun
definitely so um
i have another question one of my
favorite bits of yours is the
locker boxing bit okay
and i'm just curious how
that came about because it just
it seems like it would not be organic
it seems like it would have taken a lot
of thought
well it didn't i mean i i hate to
disappoint you but
um some dreams out here
well i just have a very uh a very
kind of different way of parenting where
um
you know my kids tell me everything i
tell my kids everything we don't have
any secrets
it's you know my daughter was at school
the other day
and she got a really bad cramp and
she made a noise and this boy looked at
her and she goes i'm menstruating
and he looked like he was gonna vomit he
was so sick to his stomach
and she doesn't realize that you know
she talks about it all the time when
she's home and i talk about it with her
she doesn't realize
not all dudes talk about it all the time
so
which i think they should it'd be a lot
easier for everybody but
um so if you remember the bit before the
locker boxing i made a
a chain where i ripped off a piece of
the chain
every day up until my son's 18th
birthday because i was gonna punch him
in the face
and i i really really was going to
but when he came downstairs i couldn't
do it
because you know you think about it like
this is my baby boy i'm not gonna
punch him in his face so and then we
went outside and we
we locker box and then everything as i
tell the story i mean that's one of
those we talked about luck joel earlier
this is one of these these bits that's
lucky because
it was just presented to me non-stop
it's like oh you think the joke is over
with the locker boxing outside it isn't
here's an email
that tells you what you know this urban
dictionary says locker boxing is and i
was like oh wow that's another punch
line and
you know it just kept kind of coming in
naturally i didn't
really have to do much with it besides
tell the story
now my understanding is that it wasn't
actually in urban dictionary was it
it didn't go in until after your special
came out well i took a picture of it
uh all right excuse me the guy in i
think it was
west what am i thinking of arkansas
what's the capital of arkansas
why can't i think of it little thank you
west or west little rock maybe anyways
sent me an email with a screenshot of it
from urban dictionary i think the thing
that
changed is in the definition
it uses part of my joke as like the how
to
you know how they always use the word in
a sentence i think i think that they
changed it to a
part of my joke to for that sentence i
think that's what changed
okay yeah what was the bit before the
the pubic hair uh
that that brought me to the locker
boxing yeah you said you were breaking
the chain
oh right so so i just had a bit
um from the album before i think
where i had made a construction paper
chain like you do when you're a little
kid for christmas and you rip off one of
the links every day until christmas
well i was ripping off one of the links
every day until his 18th birthday
so i could punch him in the face and i
it was it was in our house
with a gold link at the end of it and so
he knew it was coming too
oh that's great yeah i have a i have a
20 year old and 18 year old daughter
so okay we talk about menstruation a lot
too
yeah i mean i think you have to you
can't uh you know
all the quiet all i mean imagine being a
young woman and going through all this
stuff
and then one of the two people that are
supposed to help you get through life
shuts down and doesn't talk to you about
it that just seems incredibly insane to
me
definitely um one other question
uh at what point in your career were you
at
when you stopped doing open mics and i
assume it's because you were doing
enough
shows that you didn't have to do open
mics anymore is that right
well i love open mics and i would
continue to do them however i live in a
place
i was talking to joel earlier there
there isn't stand-up
so i mean if i was going to do open mics
i'd have to do like a
pat mcgann surprise show on his kids
during quarantine i don't know if you
guys
saw those pat mcgann is such a funny
comedian
incredible from chicago has a new
special out
um and he would just his kids would be
watching tv and he's like
it's time for the surprise show and he'd
walk out and his kids would be like dad
come
on and he's like doing bits about them
oh it's so funny
but uh why did i why did i tell you that
i forgot where i was going with this oh
open mic so so
that's basically what i would have to do
to have an open mic i would just have to
do it in front of my son and daughter um
anytime i can do an open mic i i choose
to
like if i'm in a town where you know
you're doing a show on thursday
and there's a later open mic i try to
get to that open mic just because it's
fun and even if you don't go
up it's awesome to see that
that new comedian excitement
you know sometimes you forget because
you're on the road and it's like
oh god i've been on the road for 10
straight days and
you know sometimes it feels like work
not always not i mean not even
a small percentage of the time but
sometimes it does but to go in
and see a new comedian's energy
and passion for it it's like it's great
like a little fountain of youth there
yeah and then one last one um
i heard you talk about keeping all of
your hotel keys when you were featuring
on the road
that way that way you could go in and
get free breakfast
at any hotel yeah um are there any other
uh is there any other advice you have
for saving money while on the road
well joel brought it up earlier i would
um
if you know if you have an off night so
i would either camp i love camping
some people don't love camping though so
i would either go to a uh
a state park and i would camp or
my recommendation is always to sleep in
uh in a walmart parking lot
because they have lights and they have
cameras
because truckers park there overnight
and you know rest stops don't have
cameras but walmart parking lots do so
um at least if you get murdered you know
your family will have closure
closure
[Laughter]
i've heard you say that joke a few
different ways in a few different
interviews but closure
i think that's the closure there i think
that's the the wording of it that that's
[Laughter]
[Music]
hilarious i didn't mean to cut you off
there john was that your last question
or
yep that's all i had nice well thanks a
lot john
and uh good luck with everything
especially your kiddos
and uh have fun at the open mic tonight
thank you i will yeah good luck john
take it easy guys
awesome and really just the um
just kind of in closing here and this
dan's been making a lot of
uh dan maynard has been making a lot of
positive comments about you
and um just as we land this plane he
does mention about your ability to
create a connection with the audience to
make everyone feel involved
how what kind of tips do you have for a
comic when it
when it comes to connecting with an
audience and creating that genuine
authentic connection
well i think being hung over and
forgetting your set is a great place to
start all right because then you have to
talk to people and get to know them
no um i mean it depends
you know it depends on what style of
comedy you're doing i am very
genuinely interested in other people
right
so i know the best way for everyone to
have fun
is to kind of knock down some barriers
as we go
and uh part of that is just talking to
people and making them comfortable i
used to go after hecklers
so quickly and so aggressively
and that's just young man you
know so
um now i i try to engage i try to figure
out why they're heckling like i told you
before you know
someone calls me a racist or whatever i
would want to know why i just genuinely
am i'm curious about people
and so i ask a lot of questions and you
know
i think hecklers are taken aback by that
because they expect to be on defense
but i'll let you play offense i just
want to know what's what's making you
yell at me that's all
yeah that's that can be scary for newer
comics so when you when you get a
heckler
what is like what it what is your game
plan at that point
i don't really have one i mean if if you
are
i can normally now i can calm almost any
heckler down
again because i don't come over the top
i don't start a fight
i just want to know what's going on with
them um
you know when i was 25 and a 35 year old
heckled me
no 35 year old on planet earth wants to
hear
questions from a 25 year old to you know
no 35 year old thinks a 25 year old has
any wisdom
but now if i get heckled by a 35 year
old i'm 45.
so now it's that it's switched a little
bit
where i can be you know i'm seeing big
brother dad
whatever it is and it's a little
different because
you know i have gray in my hair and gray
in my beard and i i seem like i might
know some things even if i don't i seem
like i might so
i think that's helped quite a bit as
well but
also calming down and just taking the
piss and vinegar out of my set
has been fantastic yeah i found me
smiling i used to be kind of like
furrow browed and a little more of like
can you believe this
but as i smile more the baby like it was
the baby face works more if i'm more
sarcastic as opposed to condescending
you know sure absolutely i could see
that
so let's uh the final thing here uh we
always end this episode with and thank
you so much for being so generous with
your time
as well my pleasure thanks for having me
um you've helped a lot of comics today
um we always ask what is what is your
favorite
uh piece of advice what are like do you
have any closing advice
that you could bestow upon this next
generation of great comics
hmm i should have had that ready
let me just think for one second we're
guys we're going to go dead air here for
10 seconds
problem no problem at all and thank you
to everyone who has been tuning in as
well
asking such great questions yeah thanks
thanks for everyone that showed up
that's uh
fantastic i really appreciate it and um
hi to the people i know and and hi with
this hand to the people that i
just shown up now um
[Music]
i would say stop caring
about the outcome so much
that's going to be what i say i mean
let's
let's put comedy aside for a second and
let's just go real life right you see
teenagers
again 21 year old 16 year old and
they're going through a relationship or
something
and they see it kind of starting to
crumble and even if it's not a good idea
they hang on
so tightly that they basically
strangle the other person you know um
but i think and when i say don't care
i don't mean go up there in a robe and
slippers and tell people to f off and
all this stuff i'm saying
don't make it the end-all be-all because
you're gonna get something
out of it right if you don't kill you're
gonna get something out of it
i remember there was a set where
when i was younger i used to let the
crowd dictate the jokes i went to
i was like oh they like dirty so i'm
gonna do dirty and then one day
i just couldn't no joke i picked was
working and i was like well forget it
i'm just gonna do what i want to do and
they can come along or they don't have
to and that's it
and i think once i let go a little bit
that helped
a ton because then it was just
you're more emotionally involved in
things you want to talk about
and so people can read emotions
i mean we're social creatures so if
you're up there
you know i used to tell a joke for i
think it was like six straight years
about hitting a pheasant with my car and
my buddies
watched a set of mine once and they go
what were you thinking about up there
when you're telling that joke
and i go i was thinking about what i was
going to order when i got off stage how
did you know that they're like well your
eyes glazed over and you became like a
robot
i think when you're emotionally involved
in what you're saying
people feel it you know and then
again social creatures if you're
empathetic emotions kind of
feed off one another so then the crowd
kind of gets into it a little bit more
and
so i would just say oh you have to sum
it up with three words what did i just
say for 10 minutes
be patient boom
be patient let it go that seems to be
yeah just be patient enjoy
the ride enjoy the process yep i would
say so
well is there um in the the closing
the closing bell here would you mind
looking into the camera and
saying your name and why comics should
listen to hot breath
sure hi my name is chad daniels
and i think you should listen to hot
breath because you may
or may not get some great advice
all right chad daniels everyone let's
give him a round of applause
and where can where can we go where what
links can we share to help support you
here chad
uh you can my website chaddaniels.com
i'll have my tour dates for
when i go back on the road that's
starting in january
hopefully we're seeing some spikes so
we're just gonna have to be patient with
this
um and then you can follow me that chad
daniels
on twitter or instagram however i need
to let you know
that i am off social media for one full
week
i have uh erased the apps from my phone
because i need some peace and quiet whoa
so i thought it'd be a good time to do
it so
you're right now in the middle of being
off social media
yeah just today today's day one
today's day one i am however we talked
about dan maynard quite a bit i am gonna
hop
on there on my computer to read his
message
be careful have you seen the social
dilemma on netflix yet
i have yeah okay
it's be careful if you get on facebook
that's the
that's the gateway drug you know
but uh we'll we'll definitely share
those links in the comments and show
description
and uh chad it's been an absolute
pleasure to have you on the show thank
you so much thanks for having me andrew
i appreciate it
all right thank you
all right we're off we're off air
oh all right there you have it hot
breath the verse
chad daniels go forth with your days now
our entire mission here at hot breath is
to cultivate the next generation of
great comics if you'd like to join that
generation
go join our facebook group it's linked
in the show description
and start connecting with other comics
around the world and start leveling up
your comedy
i am comedian and host of hot breath
joel buyers feel free to connect with me
on social media
at top breath pot or at joel byers
comedy with any questions you have
i want to help however i can that is the
whole goal
of the hot breath verse so have fun out
there
tell your comic friends to join the
hopper at the verse
and we'll see you next week
you